now since the February report the the
news on these indicators has been mixed
there are some signs that the labor
market is listening a little though at a
slow at a slower Pace than we expected
in February it nevertheless remains
tight
employment growth has been partially met
by an increase in labor market
participation especially amongst younger
people
the number of vacancies has come down
from the very high levels as well a
chart five shows the ratio of vacancies
to unemployment which is a key measure
of Labor Market tightness has fallen as
a result
similarly job to job flows have declined
a little in the most recent data
in line with the data businesses across
the United Kingdom tell our network of
agents that recruitment difficulties
have eased in recent months
employees are moving jobs less
frequently and employers are getting
more applications for job vacancies
nominal pay growth is shown in chart six
and that has also Fallen back slightly
in line with our February projections
near-term indicators such as hmrc
payroll data in the KPMG Rec salaries
index suggests that pay growth could
ease further later this year
and we hear the same thing from our
network of Agents
meanwhile Services price inflation in
shot 7 remains elevated broadly as
expected in the February report
this may reflect some rebuilding of
margins as well as wage growth and the
indirect effects of higher energy and
other input costs
the extent to which firms have already
passed true higher costs will influence
the pace at which Services inflation
declines
so while CPI inflation is expected to
fall quite sharply as energy costs begin
to ease albeit at a somewhat slower
paced than projected in February given
the near-term outlook for food prices
the outlook for inflation further out is
more uncertain
and depends on the extent of persistence
in wage and price setting
as shown in chart 8 in the in the mpc's
Baseline modal projection which is
conditional on a market implied path for
bank rate that Peaks at four and three
quarter percent in the fourth quarter of
the year
an increasing degree of economic slack
combined with declining external
pressures leads inflation to fall
materially below the two percent Target
in the medium term
but the committee continues to judge
that the risks to inflation are skewed
significantly to the upside
primarily reflecting the possibility of
more persistence and domestic wage and
price setting
we think the unwinding of second round
effects may take longer than it did for
them to emerge
the current circumstances are so unusual
however that it is hard to be precise
about the extent of this asymmetry
so we've not made it part of our
Baseline modal projection
nevertheless the MPC judges that
relative to the Baseline projection of
significant declines in inflation to
levels below targets there remains
material upside risks over the medium
term
reflecting those risks conditional on
the market implied path for Bank rates
the NPC's mean forecast path for
inflation is at or just below the two
percent Target
at years two and three
I want to emphasize the point that
having those large upside risk on
inflation does not call into question
meeting the inflation Target in our
projection using Market rates
now upside risks may not materialize and
so the NPC's Baseline modal forecast
remains for inflation to fall below the
Target in the medium term conditional on
the market path for bank rate
the return to the transmission of
monetary policy
monetary policy is now working to bring
inflation down
changes in Bank rates seem to have
passed through as would be expected into
new mortgage and corporate borrowing
rates
overseas bank failures have resulted in
asset price volatility since the
February report
and spreads on UK bank's wholesale
funding Rose
but this was short-lived
applying little impact on the interest
rates facing households and companies
while pulse through into household site
deposit rates has been muted rates on
term deposits and fixed-rate bonds have
risen more in line with changes in
reference rates
these changes are still working their
way through the economy
for example why we've why we have seen
higher rates being quoted on new
mortgages Illustrated here
by rates on a new two-year 75 lend to
Value mortgages that's the blue line
as well as the effective rates on new
mortgages more generally which is the
orange to Red Line
the effective rates on the whole
existing stock of mortgages which is the
purple line are still catching up
given such lags in the transmission of
monetary policy the rise in bank rate
since December 2021 will weigh more on
the economy in the coming quarters and
the MPC factors this into its policy
decisions
the bottom line here is that over this
period of time the mortgage Market has
changed to being a more fixed rate
Market
so let me conclude with the Marshall
policy decision today
at this meeting the committee has voted
to increase bank rate by 0.25 percentage
points to four and a half percent
in doing so the NPC is continuing to
address the risk of more persistent
strength and domestic price and wage
setting as represented by the upward
skew in the projected distribution for
CPI inflation
the pace at which inflationary pressures
ease will depend on the evolution of the
economy
including the impact of the significant
increases in Bank rates so far
uncertainties around the Global
Financial and economic Outlook also
remain elevated
the NPC will continue to monitor closely
indications of persistent inflationary
pressures including the tightness of
labor market conditions the behavior of
wage growth and services price inflation
if there were to be evidence of more
persistent pressures then further
tightening and monetary policy would be
required
the MPC will adjust bank rate as
necessary to return inflation to Target
sustainably in the medium term in line
with its remit
so thank you and with that Ben Dave and
I'll be happy to take your questions
usual process for questions please once
you get a hold of them
could let us know your name and where
you're from and if you can limit it to
one question a piece please so we can
get around everyone we'll start with ED
and then sue
thank you uh Ed Conway from Sky News
um in some senses some people would say
that you know this is the biggest test
of the banks uh the bank since becoming
independent this rise in inflation the
the rise in interest rates what would
you say to those who say that it's it's
effectively failing that test failing to
see the rise in inflation failing to see
how sticky it's become now it's up at
the top failing to understand the nature
of food price inflation as well
do you think that those failures matter
in your ability to to maintain
credibility
well I think you're right at that
the backdrop to this is that the shocks
that have been hitting the UK economy
and of course the global economy
actually as well we must look at it
through that lens as well have been much
larger
so we've set these shocks out and of
course I've referred to a lot of them in
my opening remarks the largest one of
which is the impact of the you know
terrible war in Ukraine on both energy
and food prices no question about that
and it's of course it's the test of this
regime is how is how we deal with them
and how we return inflation back to
Target
now I think you can look at that through
two lenses therefore one is what is
causing the shocks the second is you
know how are those shocks anticipated
and then how do we deal with them in
terms of returning inflation Target
because that is the objective of the
regime obviously that we have
sustainable inflation over the medium
terms with sustainably low at Target
inflation
that is what we're doing
um we have to you know we have to adjust
from meeting to meeting as we see news
and I'll pick on one piece of news that
you mentioned I think the the point on
food prices let me just come to that
there is a very big underlying shock in
food prices and you know we showed I
showed the chart which showed the same
thing is going on in Europe
as a whole
now
I think the news that we've had is not
about persistence in the sense of
long-run persistence
it's the question of how
over what time this shock Works its way
through the the system if you like
and how quickly we expect that to
dissipate now what we're hearing and as
I said I hear it around the country
which I've been doing a lot since we
were last here
is an expectation that it will we will
see a reduction in food in food and food
inflation indeed we already seeing so
some of that beginning
but it is taking longer and the the
reasons I hear that it's taking longer
are sometimes to do with the impact of
energy prices and food production
sometimes to do with you know hedgings
hedging approaches that have been used
at the commodity price level so that
although as I said commodity prices you
know started to fall last year it's
taking longer to come through now I
think you know I'm happy to sort of in a
sense debate well how much of that is
predictable and how much of that is is
emerging but those are the things we
have to deal with and yes we do revise
our views as we see new evidence I think
that's appropriate
so
thanks hi Sue Chan from the telegraph
just following up on that then I mean
this is the biggest upgrade to your
growth forecast in the NPC's history
what would you say to people who said
that in the past the bank of England has
been too gloomy and just on those food
prices given the work you've done on
price setting behavior and how it's
changed do you think supermarkets have
been as quick to cut prices as they have
been raising them
well only upward revision
um and Ben may want to come in on this
as well I mean if you look at what's
happened well let's take it back to when
we were sitting here in November
there has been a very substantial fall
in Energy prices I mean the the biggest
news has been a very substantial fall in
gas prices and that does feed through
clearly and that's fed through in a
positive way
so you know we take that on board that
was not anticipated let's face it when
we were sitting here in early November
we were looking at a prospect of a very
difficult winter you know some
probability that Europe was going to you
know experience periods where gas
supplies may be restricted it all looked
very Bleak and that was reflected in
pricing and and that has turned out not
to be as bad as expected so that's a
piece of you know that's one piece of
news
second piece of news as I said is that
we've obviously at this time taken on
board the the measures that were
introduced in the budget which has
happened since since February and yeah
that has a positive effect in this in
certainly in the year or so ahead
thirdly Global conditions have improved
so I'll give you another example of that
you know the impact of China's uh ending
of its zero covert policy I think has
been much more muted Than People many
people expected it to be
and the fourth Factor as I said isn't
here I think we you know we do say yes
we understand this that I think the
economy has turned out to be more
resilient to this than we we expected it
to be so you know all of those things
come together and it's you know it's
appropriate that we revise can I make
the point I mean I will slightly to put
a downer on it for a moment if you don't
mind I mean yes it's a very big upward
revision but the level of growth is
still very it's still weak let's be
honest I mean we have to look at both we
have to look at both change and level
here I think I mean to get the sort of
the proper position just on on on on
supermarkets I mean I I don't want to
comments on um sectors because frankly
we don't have
um what I would call sort of consistent
data I would say in the in the aggregate
data and um I'd rather helpfully
published this chart this morning which
um as one we have as well which is the
aggregate position for the UK as a whole
and it's interesting to look at because
it doesn't tell the same story that for
instance the somewhat similar chart that
the ECB has published for for the Euro
area so you don't see the same picture
in terms of the contributions uh the
component contributions
yeah so and in the aggregate chart shows
there's no increase in the profit Sharp
of national income
it's the comparison with Europe where
it's slightly different just on the
general nature of forecast one has to
remember
said it before these are conditional
forecasts
so when the conditions change the
forecast change maybe other reasons
forecast change but that's certainly a
big one
and you go back to say last August
I mean gas prices were
close to 500 pounds a therm are now 80.
what that means is that if you look
forward household energy bills are now
over four percent of income lower
projected than they were in the August
forecast
partly because we assumed
that those prices would remain and now
they've come down but I mean that is a
huge change in the conditioning
assumption it gives a big boost to the
economy
I think it's why you've seen growth
improve significantly in Europe and
Continental Europe as well as it happens
the timing of that turn here and in the
Euro area was precisely when wholesale
energy process started to climb trough
was September October and high frequency
measures of growth like the pmis
and interestingly you haven't seen the
same increase in the U.S because you
never saw the same rise in Energy prices
in the United States so this is a really
big reason for the change in growth both
in the data and in
in the forecast and another conditioning
assumption incidentally that's different
in in August and November compared with
now is that the market path of interest
rates is also low enough
so these things one should always
remember and want to remember more
generally the conditional nature of the
forecast we make
and if I can just put some numbers to
Andrew's point I mean as he said in his
opening remarks we're forecasting grapes
now of a quarter percent annual average
this year three quarters of a percent
next year that's in the table on page
28. that is up from February where we
had two negatives so we have moved from
you know minus a half this year minus a
quarter next year to two small positives
and that does reflect I mean we we've
been consistently stressing that the
economy has been hit by these negative
sharks what's happened to Energy prices
more recently is a positive shock for
the global economy for the UK economy
and we've also seen this very resilient
labor market
um we're now forecasting unemployment
will stay below four percent this year
and we've you know we're beginning to
see some improvement on inactivity that
was another negative shock we called out
it's more concentrated in students at
the moment but these are positive
underlying developments but they're
against a backdrop of still very or
relatively weak growth compared to
historically but that that it's that
kind of context which has enabled us to
revise up our growth projections
Phil and Marine
hi there fellow drink at Bloomberg um so
Energy prices have fallen but your
inflation forecast is actually higher
you've repeatedly underestimated where
inflation will be and how far rates will
need to go
um the markets have been right and you
haven't is that a fair is that a fair
sort of take away from this and I mean
in in the in November you said rates
would at the other point being that
um we're going to have rates at five
percent at the end of this year at one
percent at the end of the two-year
forecast do we need to do more on rates
or less on rates how do we how do we
read that well
can I take the second question first
because I think it's a very it's a very
important Point
um we've been very clear in the the
guidance and we've repeated the language
this time that we used in the committee
in March
that we will be guided by the evidence
so I want to be very clear on this we
are not giving what I would call a
directional steer on rates today as we
didn't last time we will be guided by
the evidence
and that's very important now we made
that we've repeated the point we've made
before which is if we see further signs
of Greater persistence
then um of course we'll have to act but
that let's be very clear and it goes
back to what Ben was saying earlier
that's a conditional statement it's not
an unconditional statement it's a
conditional statement so in other words
it states the conditions under which we
would have to act but to be very clear
we're not giving any steer we're
evidence driven on this occasion now
I'll make one point on your first
question I don't know I don't know if
they want to come in as well and that's
this the news that we've had on
inflation and you're right inflation is
you know it's just under one percent
higher at this point in time than we
expected it to be in February
interestingly as I said in my remarks
that that difference is actually really
not really about the persistent element
of inflation so if you look at Services
um if you look at
um you know wage wages and remuneration
they are actually pretty much on track
with what we brought in February the
news is mainly on on food and clothing
um
and certainly yes I mean food inflation
has been more persistent than we thought
it would be I'll just repeat the points
I made earlier
it appears to be taking longer for food
price pressures to work their way
through the system this time than we had
expected but as we said before we aren't
you these are very unusual times I mean
the models have to be treated with
caution here because the transmission of
these sorts of shocks is highly
uncertain yeah I just want to look at
them and I'm not sure
the Market's got it right we have a
market break-even rate for RPI inflation
that's certainly a year or two ago was
not predicting 10 so I don't know hang
on I don't think hang on can you can I
just answer
yeah I thought you meant
uh no I don't think that's true you've
talked about inflation though I thought
you said the Market's got it right we're
talking about inflation I thought
no well unless deal with the inflation
stuff
um and we don't predict interest rates
so I'm not sure where that comes from
but inflation
uh yeah the markets were certainly not
expecting no one was expecting 10
inflation a couple of years ago at this
point
I want to mention something of context
of Ed's question as well the sort of big
picture thing so the the scale of these
Rises and import prices we had 21 22
particularly last year
are enormous by historical standards
they're roughly speaking depends a bit
how you measure it
they cost the UK collectively about five
percent of income that's by how much
over five my guess I had a talk a few
months ago where I tried to quantify I
think it was about five and a half
percent the number in the year to the
third quarter of last year
which I think is roughly speaking twice
or even more than twice as big
as the hit from the risers and oil
prices in the mid-1970s
now at that time and headline inflation
went up and this is the point I wanted
to come back to in terms of Ed's
question the result was a huge rise in
inflation expectations more generally in
the medium term
that hasn't happened now we did see
these Break Even rates expected
medium-term inflation rates go up
quite a bit
but they actually peaked over a year ago
but they're still too high for our
liking but they are not nothing like the
response in the 70s and that is the
value of this regime and you're
absolutely right it's critical that we
maintain that value and maintain that
credibility and the task as Andrew said
is not somehow to
predict that the war was going to happen
or even its consequences for the
supplies of energy and food because I'm
not sure that's possible
it is to respond and to respond to where
in town that maintains this credibility
and ensures that inflation gets
sustainably back to two percent and
that's what that's what we'll do okay
can I just come in with one point fellow
page 89 of the report has a chart a
chart that we always have at the back of
our report which is comparing our
forecast to the average of uh of
forecasters projections and you know
what you see there is that for Q2 next
year our modal projection for inflation
is actually a market is noticeably above
the average of outside forecasters now
interestingly for the following two
years we're below but I made the points
about the way in which the committee had
looked at yeah put in a mean projection
as well which has the inflation skew in
it if you were to compare our mean
projection with the outside of the
average forecasts and by the way we
don't know to what extent these outside
forecasters use means and modes I can't
tell you the answer that question
actually our mean forecast is pretty
much the same as those
things so you know I just would push
back slightly on where we are relative
to the outside world Dave sorry I cut
across you I was just going to focus on
the very short-term forecast and
obviously recognizing that the
conditioning assumptions for those
short-term forecasts can also change you
know we are having to deal with the
whole range of shocks as they play out
both negative and now more recently
positively but just to highlight I mean
we we put these numbers now in table 1.
C the uh on page
25 we expect inflation uh to fall to 8.2
in Q2 so that's actually slightly below
what we had
in the February forecast now that's
because energy
prices and the extension of the energy
price guarantee are supporting things
there moving in the other direction
though is this recognition that food
price inflation has been higher than we
and I think others thought thought so
you've got those two offsetting factors
and we're trying to be transparent about
the path of inflation clearly it's too
high at present as Andrew stressed but
we do see it starting to come down
sharply from Q2 and then falling through
the rest of the year and being below
Target
within two years time so
in a sense those based on the current
conditioning assumptions and are
forecasting judgments that is the way to
frame the way we're approaching this as
Ben says though if you look at those
market-based measures for example break
evens you get no sense that there is
kind of a challenge to The credibility
of the framework we're not seeing that
de-anchoring of medium-term inflation
expectations in markets which would be
something that would more go to Ed's
emphasis on on credibility we're
confident about that
Marine
hi um Marine Khan from the times just to
go back to the food prices
um I'm interested in why or how the bank
seems to have been a bit blindsided by
this story given that you have a network
of Agents is it that your agents are not
asking the right questions or even that
the businesses are not really replying
honestly about their pricing behavior
and given that we sort of fail to
foresee what was going to happen with
food prices and to some extent Goods why
are you so confident that even though
they will come down as you said a bit
slowly that actually maybe companies are
are they replying honestly about their
future Behavior
so it's another good question
um
I mean I think the issue is the degree
of persistence in food inflation that
we've seen
um
I mean you can say you can go back to
the underlying shocks but that is you
know that is a question of how you read
the impact particularly of what's going
on in Ukraine I'm afraid I mean you
might remember about a year ago I said
you know something which was interpreted
quite dramatically wasn't you you know
it wasn't really meant in that sense but
more just to make the point that food is
a big issue in the shock that we're
seeing now the question then was how
long was this transmission going to go
on for and was it going to go on for you
know longer well as it turned out it
seems to have gone on for longer than
certainly sort of past experience would
would would illustrate and I I'll pick
out tooth I mean I mentioned a few
minutes ago but I'll just quickly ruin I
think there is an element of
the impact particularly of energy costs
in food production which I think
probably yes but we didn't come through
as much as it should have done so I
think that's true
I think the hardest thing to judge as I
mentioned earlier is how and by the way
I should say one of the things I find
you know our agents find I find when I'm
going around the country of course is
that the energy question we talk about
the energy question a lot for households
but it's important also to talk about it
for businesses and the energy question
of businesses is very complicated
because it really you know businesses
have contracts that run for periods of
time and get reset at very depending on
when they get reset and there's no fixed
there's no fixed time at which business
energy contracts get picked and so you
know businesses are having very
different experiences I mean I talk to a
lot of businesses their experiences are
very different because it depends just
on when you reset your contractors to
you know what your experience is and so
that can come through a very different
ways in terms of impact on pricing but I
think the other thing I'd mention is
this question about hedging I mean how
much hedging was done
and for what period of time and how
hedging Behavior responded to the
severity of the shock and I think yeah
there I think there's a lot of there's a
lot of uncertainty and there are things
we learned from this so you know that
that I I think is true
sorry yes just a couple of things on the
there's a good couple of charts
look all the charts are good but
particularly good is the middle of the
report 50 page 57 and eight a couple of
things on throughput actually well one
on 58 Andrew already showed you in the
introduction
the fact that food price inflation is so
high is not just because of quotes
pricing strategies of firms mosander
indicated their costs have gone up
enormously
and minimum wage went up Energy prices
much has a lot of energy use in food
production
and we don't just rely on what food
retailers tell us about what they're
going to do because
we know that what they do will be driven
by these other things to some degree so
if you look up for this is for for goods
X energy on the left so that's more than
just food at the left-hand side of 28 to
chart 2.18
you know we know we can see you here
there's quite strong evidence
from the producer pricing side that we
think the price of retail Goods
inflation the price of retail Goods will
decelerate that their inflation rate
will fall
and you can see how tight that
correlation is for food output output
price inflation hasn't come down as much
but it does seem to have Peak you see
the same in other countries if you look
at the input prices for food producers
that rate of inflation has been falling
for several months
so we do not simply listen to what the
retailers tell us who reconstruct the
forecast a little more
carefully and I should emphasize that
although that we have definitely put up
the food price inflation
for a while
by the time you get to the meaningful
part of the forecast for us sort of what
we call a policy Horizon the point at
which current changes in monetary policy
would really have an impact on inflation
so 18 months two years and Beyond
it's not having an impact we still think
based partly on this partly on what
we're seeing in underlying commodity
prices that food price inflation will
come down significantly it'll just take
a little longer than we thought three
months ago I mean just add something I
mean it's getting very specific now if
you don't want to say so so the level of
milk prices has come down actually
that's the level actually
clear in recent months
but just give me I mean I I don't live
my life in bakeries but I have been
tonight I've been going I've been to a
number of Bakers around the country
recently I know you may think I'd even
look at me
um and what they've said is it's quite
interesting I mean their response in
terms of buying you know Commodities
forward to hedge themselves
changed somewhat in response to seeing
the nature of the shock they were
there's a war going on in one of the
most you know one of the largest grain
producing countries in the world so you
know they factor that in and I think
those judgments
yep yep I mean you know we have to we
have to learn about those judgments as
we as we go along
let's go to jamana and Larry
hi jamana Versace from CNBC noted your
comments on domestic inflationary
pressures can you hear me
let me go again can you hear me now
always better okay okay noted your
comments on domestic inflationary
pressures
um private sector wage growth is running
north of seven percentage points
in order to bring that uh in line with
your price stability mandate many
economists say it needs to be closer to
three percentage points
how are you going to bring that down
without bringing about a recession or a
massive uptick in the unemployment rates
very good question
we already think it is coming down a
little right and Andrew Shady requires
with some of the indicators
what is highly unusual about this is
it's not just economic slack or the rate
of unemployment
that has driven wage growth it is very
much the second round effects of these
huge Rogers and the import prices
I gave you a number earlier for this
enormous cost of living a squeeze we've
had for the country as a whole
and so everyone's experienced this
and the result of that
big hit to real incomes we think
is that for Kauai to understandable
reasons
firms and households try and protect
those real incomes by pushing up their
nominal prices and wages respectably
now collectively unfortunately that
doesn't really solve the problem because
it's just a problem posed on us
collectively from the outside
but this is the reason why we think
those predominant reason why wages have
accelerated and domestic price prices
have accelerated for example and
services
what we've seen now is David size and
Andrew emphasize earlier is a lot of
those global prices
are declining
there's a breakdown somewhere of our
wage forecast and we expect for that
reason predominantly so independently of
the rate of unemployment and
that that will bring down wage growth
now we're actually relatively cautious
about that
uh Andrew discussed the skew
that represents a judgment
that this unwinding of the second round
effects will actually take longer than
the models are telling us it will the
models are saying yeah lore unwind quite
quickly and you'll get quite a lot of
uh fall in wage growth and domestic
price setting without the need for
harana but we've been more cautious than
that
and indeed unemployment does go up in
the forecast
less than in February but the tops go
off but I think you have to understand
that but these highly unusual
circumstances and what has driven up
these
these rates of growth to begin with
it's partly the tight labor market
but mostly as other stuff and that other
stuff is unwinding
Larry Elliott of the Guardian
um interest rates have now gone up 12
times in a row inflation as you say is
still too high above 10 percent by any
stretching the imagination that seems to
me to be a policy failure somewhere
along the line now rather than blaming
Vladimir Putin for this or wage
bargainers trying to negotiate uh pay
Rises for their workers isn't it time
for the bank to own up to its part in
the in this policy failure and say sorry
to the householders who are paying going
to be paying more for their mortgages
sorry to the small businesses who are
facing much higher overdrafts isn't it
time for the bank to say sorry we messed
up
well Larry we don't use the language of
blame I I we must be clear on this I
mean and I do read you know articles
which you know are cast in those terms
and I don't use the language of blame
um what I do think we have to do is set
out the underlying
shocks that are going on in the world
economy and the UK economy that that in
a sense can cause this situation
and we do push back Ben made a speech on
it a couple of weeks ago on some of the
some of the arguments which says the
underlying cause is not to do with these
other things that it's to do with the
way in which partnership policy has been
set in the past but I want to
distinguish two things here so that's
the first point I'll make I think it's
important to set out the causes but not
in the language of blame we're not using
language of blame
um if you want to argue that the war in
Ukraine has not caused inflation I think
we'd be happy to have that debate with
you but we don't agree with you I'm
afraid now the second I think
approach to this question is is
sometimes I think more important which
is okay yeah let's take those sort of
causes and then say did you as the bank
of England respond
either quickly enough or forcefully
enough to those causes could you have
anticipated those those causes and
therefore offset the experience now I
think that's a debate that yeah we've
had for some time and I think you know
happy to have it uh again as it were I
would make the point that you know as
I've made many times before that there
is a level of what I know if you don't
mind me saying so hindsight in many of
these judgments the other thing I would
say is I think Ben has set out and
certainly sylvana Turner is set out in
in speeches they've made in the past and
if you take Ukraine as a you know as a
good case
you have to make two assumptions one is
that
we could have foreseen the war
uh far enough in advance to have
actually taken action to offset it so
that's a I mean I don't get beyond that
point but I'll set the second one out
just for the sake of argument if you
don't mind and then that you would have
taken Massive offsetting Action
uh in the middle of the covid uh
recession
to to offset it now we could debate that
second point but actually I'm afraid I
don't even get to that point because the
idea that we could have foreseen the
Ukraine war you know 18 months or two
years before it happened I mean I'm
afraid that is that's a stretch Beyond
near to which I wouldn't go
but that's not the language of blame
Larry I don't want to use that that
language I think we should have a debate
about you know how does policy respond
but I think it is important that we set
out the underlying causes here
thank you Chris Giles from the financial
times I'm not going to use the language
of blame nor the language of hindsight
just the evaluation
um you the NPC says there's a pretty
much a 50 50 chance that inflation will
be above its Target all the way to 2026
that would be five years of above Target
inflation 50 50 chance
is that good performance how would you
evaluate the performance is that
something you would be proud of
well as you can see from the way
obviously we've set the presentation out
of course that's yeah we always present
the fan chart so you can always do that
um
on the you know both on the mean case so
let's stick with the mean case for the
moment which is the one that you know
where we've put more persistence in than
the model would suggest and that really
goes to what Ben was just saying about
asymmetry it brings inflation back to
Target sort of towards the end of next
year
now
you know of course there's a debate
about you know how quickly we should
bring inflation back to Target and how
how appropriate are various different
settings you know and we have to balance
that out because we've yeah we've got
also got language you know in our
objectives about trade-offs
um and we will go on considering you
know very carefully as we meet what is
the right path to bring inflation down
on but I think this you know this path
that we've got
is not unreasonable given the scale of
the shock that we've had
I mean we have to bear in mind that the
very large scale of the shot that we've
had
and I think we have to sort of consider
yes you could consider paths that would
be faster because after all bear in mind
you've quoted you know you've quoted one
side of the fan chart you can quote the
other side as well
um but I think that's you know what we
have is I think an appropriate path and
I'll just go back to the point I made to
Phil's question which is uh we will
obviously be driven by the evidence at
each meeting and consider appropriately
but there is no bias at the moment in
our in our setting of rates uh looking
forward to Dave and just to use the the
framing you you use Chris around I think
any evaluation would have to take
account of the fact that we've been
we in the global economy has been hit by
two you know once in a century shocks in
quick succession again not using the
language of blame just recognizing the
world that we and other central banks
find ourselves in so we have a pandemic
then we have a major
uh pandemic certainly once in Century
first major war in Europe since the
second world war and these have had very
significant impacts
on
um
on prices and on price setting and if
you look back
um at the track record you know we
started putting up rates in December
when Omicron was we were still trying to
make sense of the Omicron variant when I
say we I mean the country collectively I
remember there was quite a lot of
surprise at that time that we had put up
uh rates against that Health backdrop
and then as I've described the shocks
we've had
from from the terrible war in Ukraine
since then which are still playing out
and they're playing out in different
ways for different sectors so we've
discussed a lot today rightly what's
happened to food prices
but also and and you know that that
originates with uh the war in Ukraine in
terms of the shocks from that but also
there are other shocks that have hit
food prices and we as we as monetary
policy makers have to deal with that
world and I think an evaluation of us
and you know of other central banks
because of I mean it is the case that we
started to tighten policy before other
central banks uh particularly before the
fed and the ECB has to take account of
the situation that we found ourselves in
over this period which has just been an
extraordinary period for the for the
world economy for the UK economy and for
monetary policy
ribbon in charge show this probability
it's their probability of being below
no no but you said it's not and we get
it's not late 26 presidents
I think someone told me the first and
second quarter of 25 just to be clear
and it's below two percent throughout
afterwards
of course not but of course not that's
not what I said
I just want to be accurate about the
premise of the questions the points
Chris I think we're all making is the
debate we're very happy to have is what
is the you know the best way to refer
yeah to to go back to price stability
given the shocks we've had and yeah Dave
made the point very well these are two
huge events in history
David was left
uh so David Millican from Reuters um I
know sort of in the military policy
report it talks a little bit about sort
of the lagged effect to sort of past
tightening obviously sort of this is
difficult to sort of Judge sort of
things have changed sort of quite a lot
sort of since the bank of England's last
tightening cycle I was wondering sort of
how confident can you be that you're not
sort of in the process of over
tightening because obviously you've got
sort of two members of the monetary
policy committee who for a number of
months have sort of voted against sort
of rate Rises so how short can you be
that you're not sort of overshooting
here well it's a very good question
because during this round we have spent
I think appropriately a lot of time on
on what we call a transmission mechanism
um and how it's changed now you know I
showed the chart of the mortgage Market
very deliberately
um because that is probably the most
interesting I think area of the
transmission mechanism for the reason
that it has changed so much over time
here we now have in the UK a
predominantly fixed rate mortgage Market
not fixed rate in the way the US has
obviously but it's still a fixed rate
over a period of time I think around
about 85 percent of the stock of
mortgages in this country is is now
fixed rate whereas if you go back I
deliberately showed the long run version
of that chart to take it back to a point
when that was not the case
and as that child showed I mean we yeah
we've still got quite a lot of pass
through to come in in that world more so
than we would have had in the past at
this point in time and so yes I mean two
things that is a very Lively subject of
debate in the committee we've we however
we factor in what we think is the you
know the pass through now so it's all
factored into our assessment but yeah of
course there's still because we haven't
seen this sort of thing happen before we
haven't had a tightening cycle with this
mortgage Market
um there is a lot of debate around that
and I'm sure you know there's a lot of
there has to be quite a lot of judgment
in that debate
um
hi oh
not terribly well
um oh
thank you
thanks very much
um yeah devil Jordan from the BBC
um I'm just wondering what do you say to
people who are struggling to make ends
meet
um do they do people as Hugh pill
suggested need to accept that they're
poorer
I I am very very dark and we are very
conscious that you know this this
inflation all inflation is difficult and
particularly for those least well off
this inflation is particularly difficult
for those least well off because it is
concentrated as we've discussed today in
what are called the essentials of Life
Food and energy and the people on Lower
incomes have a larger proportion of
their consumption is is the essentials
of Life Food and energy being the
obviously the largest elements very very
conscious of that point we Face the
difficult situation that as Ben has said
you know there has been a very
substantial hit to national income
caused by these external shocks which
takes the take the national real income
which takes the form of higher inflation
that is passing through and we have to
deal with that
now I you mentioned what he said let me
be very clear on this yeah
economics of the hit to national income
are clear but I think it's very I want
it to be very clear that we are very
sensitive to the position of people on
particularly all people but particularly
people on Lower incomes I I don't think
huge choice of words was was was the
right one in that sense I have to be
honest
um and I think he would agree with me
um but I what I'm afraid we can't duck
is this very big hit to national income
which we have to deal with and we have
to yeah we have to we have to deal with
it and of course as we've said a lot we
have to deal with the risk that that
leads to second round domestic inflation
effects can I just no I just wanted to
say in that respect something that's I
think important to emphasize which is
that because as I said earlier some of
these Global prices many of them
have stopped rising and indeed some
those related to the pandemic shortages
for example but most obviously Energy
prices have actually been falling
there is some relief here and you can
see it in this forecast I don't want to
overemphasize this because the levels
are still at these prices are still much
higher than they were before
and we'll remain so in this forecast but
in terms of the growth rate there is a
little relief so if you look at real
labor income for example
in this forecast in the year to the
fourth quarter of this year so through
the course of 2023 that is not projected
to grow and to grow quite a bit by over
two and a half percent
which would actually be the best annual
growth rate we've had for about five
years
now in the long run that growth rate
depends on you know improvements and
productivity and so forth and it's not
the case these process will fall forever
but
that for is beginning to provide a
little relief and we are beginning to
see real income growth through the
course of this year
thank you governor for your presentation
we see now that inflation in the US is
4.9 in April 7 in the Eurozone in April
just putting this in international
context why do you think it is that UK
inflation 10.1 percent still in March as
you now well know has not only been
higher than across much of the advanced
industrialized world but also far from
transitory has actually been
particularly stubborn
could I make one point I think Ben wants
to come at another Point can I make a I
mean it's a rather sort of mechanical
point but I think it's important to make
at this point um because you're right to
point out Liam why has inflation not
come down you know faster in this
country there is a particular point
about energy prices uh and the energy
price setting a mechanism in this
country actually it has quite a lot to
do with the fact that if you go back we
go back a year now actually
um
before the arrangements were changed the
off gem price setting mechanism worked
was set every only every six months
that's important the reason I say that
is because that's why we have a very big
base effect coming in for the number
that's going to be really the April
number that's going to be released in
two months and why actually those those
base effects have come free rather
faster in Continental Europe or some I
mean economy was a bit of a mixture
obviously but I just want to emphasize
that's an important Point uh in the
current comparison
um there was a bit of a flip side to
that actually a year or so ago but
that's a very important point in the
current point of comparison yeah I think
that is
actually the vast majority of that
difference with Europe is that
so if you look at core inflation rates
in March
we are hot in Europe 6.2 versus 5.7
but the vast bulk of that you know what
is actually overall a 3.2 percentage
point gap
is this point about energy
so couple with if you include petrol
prices or overall energy
domestic energy and petrol it's still 40
higher in the UK it was in March 40
higher than the year earlier in in
Europe the numbers negative in the
United States it's minus 10 at inflation
rate for energy and a lot of that has to
do with the way that the off gem cap is
set it's much more lagged therefore the
effect
so the effect of these Rises are still
here for us I mean it will come down
but it and it will come down quite
predictably because we can see exactly
what's going to happen to the camp we
know what happened a year earlier
but it will take a little longer so this
is probably I don't want to probably the
maximum Gap
but that is the the vast bulk of the
difference is this difference in energy
process so with the US by the way the
difference is not just timing but as you
know they never saw the same rise in
wholesale gas prices to begin with
Jack and then John Paul
hi there Jack Bonner from city am I
trying to go back to the transmission
mechanism that you touched on there and
there's obviously a bit in the report
today saying that it's kind of been
blunted the way it transmits through the
mortgage Market because we've now got a
new a new shaver mortgage Market if you
coincide that with the inflation
forecast you're saying quite a lot of
the drop is being driven by supply side
measures so Energy prices falling free
prices falling as well is there a
question amongst the mnpc now that the
actual effectiveness of monetary policy
in in taming inflation how how effective
is it and has it been blunted as a
result of a change in some of the the
economic structure in the UK well I I
don't think type one's coming out I
wouldn't use the word blunted I think we
have to yeah we have to adapt our view
of the transmission mechanism to the
markets that we have around us as it
were and the mortgage Market has changed
and therefore we have to you know adapt
our view of the transmission of monetary
policy and of course that then feeds
back into our decisions so rather than
blunted I would say we you know we have
to yeah we understand we have to adapt
to what the transmission mechanism is
yeah I mean this cash flow effect that
that
that is driven by uh the nature of the
of the mortgage market and the structure
I'd say it's slowed rather than blunted
relative it's going to take time to come
through but as the chart Andrew showed
we think on the stock only about 70
basis points has come through out of a
total if you look a quoted rate if you
look at quoted rates on the most popular
products you know you're up at 300 basis
points so there's a long way to go but
that will build up this is not although
we've put all these charts and in the
box today this is not news to us we knew
that the mortgage Market had changed and
we've been factoring it into our
um forecasts for some time overall I
mean we're continuing to work on this
but overall we don't think that the
overall impact of the transmission
mechanism is any less than in the we
think is broadly the same
um but and those impacts on demand and
are coming through they will come
through more Market you you'll see that
as if you look at uh the summary table
in the forecast it shows that we go from
a position of currently excess demand as
slack builds up we will you know and
other factors take effect we will move
into an opening up of spare capacity we
do expect some rise uh regrettably in
unemployment but that we think that that
is necessary it's only it's a rise now
to four and a half percent so less than
the more than five you know Peak or
endpoint unemployment we had before and
so those those features are still
playing a part but you're right as well
to emphasize the role that the supply
side and Supply shocks are played
throughout this period in which we we
consistently talk about because we think
they are relevant to the inflation that
we're experiencing and how price setting
is developing but the demand effects
from from what we're doing and what we
have to do in terms of monetary policy
we we're we're still confident are going
to come through
last two questions Sean Paul and then
halia
thanks uh John Paul Ford Rochas from The
Daily Mail
um just following up partly on a
previous question
um you said that Hugh pills language
wasn't the right language perhaps you
agree that it was insensitive as some
people think
um at the same time the head of it under
Stock Exchange is saying that um
Executives need to be paid more to
attract them to London which seems quite
starkly different from from what you're
saying and you've also said in the
monastery policy report that um the
pass-through of higher rates to Savers
is unusually weak so I just wonder
whether you think that people in your
position people in the city people at
Banks ought to be setting an example so
should you should you pill should others
in the Bank of England be refusing pay
Rises I kind of say that's what I've
done so I mean just as a matter of fact
okay
um should
um people in the city stop talking about
higher
um higher pay for executives and should
Banks be doing more to pass through rate
hikes to Savers well just to restraint
certainly look I want to speak for
myself I have I have not taken a pay
rise so that just just to emphasize that
point on on the level of pay rise for
executives I mean it's obviously these
things are set by firms not by us I've
been very clear as a you know my past
and in my presence as a regulator of
banks that we have quite extensive
regulation which seeks to create the
right incentives for a senior executive
remuneration but it's not about it's not
about the level it's about the so I'm
very clear on this point it's for firms
to set that
on your point about about deposits
I think and we we go into this quite a
bit in the report actually
so it is true that the rate of
pass-through to site deposits has been
muted I think we use that word actually
muted
the rate of pass-through of our interest
rate Rises to term deposits and fixed
rate deposits has actually been much
faster and is not very dissimilar to the
to the actual the increases that that
have gone through into the official rate
now I'm not surprised in one sense by
that because as a let me again put my
bank regulator hat on and financial
stability hat on the since the global
financial crisis the liquidity regime
has been changed so that we it greatly
incentivize uh Banks holding term
deposits
not got time now but if you go back to
the recent experience of Silicon Valley
Bank and so on you and you probably
understand why I mean that's a sensible
thing to do now what we have seen is
interestingly but not surprisingly I
think this is sensible is that there's
been some flow out of site deposits into
into term deposits it appears and that's
exactly what you'd expect given the
pricing differential and and the point I
would make is that I think it's
important that people shop around and
that we have competition in the banking
system I mean that's those pricing
mechanisms should should take effect in
that sense
yeah
ibrahimi Channel 4 News Governor you
talked about the mortgage Market
changing but are you worried about those
people who are rolling off their fixed
term mortgages there's millions of them
and for them the impact of these 12 rate
Rises is astonishing and very difficult
well let me let me say again what I've
said before because it's very important
that we are very very aware of the
effect that this inflation is having and
the consequences of this inflation is
having on household so please do not
think that when we're not in any sense
we are
now I think it's important that we
obviously you know they're very aware of
what these effects are and as Dave was
saying that we'd take those into account
that's important
the other thing I would say is and
something we've done again I'll draw on
the financial stability side of the bank
for a moment that again you know for the
last you know not far off a decade now
we have had policies in place to limit
the proportion of mortgages which are at
the more sort of the extreme end of the
sort of the loan to income ratio now
that just to be clear that was done as a
matter of financial stability it wasn't
a social policy intervention because
that's not for us but I would say that
you know one thing that I think will
help is that that does obviously limit
some of the more extreme impacts that
we've had in the past
we also again this is not to do with the
bank of England we've got much stronger
Protections in place now for yeah which
mean that there will people people do
not have their houses repossessed in the
ways that they used to be repossessed
again you know my my old uh my old crew
at the FCA have been very active in that
field and I think that's you know that's
that's appropriate
um but you know let me come back to the
first points I made you're right of
course these these things have serious
impacts with very sensitive to this but
we if we don't tackle inflation it will
be worse for people that's the that's
the bottom line I'm afraid
thanks very much everyone
very very patient
thank you for taking my question Lucy
Harga m i market news just wanted to ask
um given the recent volatility and the
projections can financial markets still
rely on the bank of England's longer
term projections as a reliable
communication tool
well we spend a lot of time and we have
a lot of Staff who spend a lot of time
assessing you know volatility and
financial markets to help us to read
through that and you I mean you're right
it is interesting now it's interesting
in the period before you know since we
lost the NPC last met that we've had
obviously quite a lot of volatility in
financial markets because obviously
we've had some very very high profile
events going on in in World Financial
and World Financial system
seriously we've done in the UK it's been
a little bit of a round trip and we've
ended up sort of not far off where we
started so that made the NPC's task a
bit easier in this case sometimes but no
look we have to spend a lot of time
interpreting this because of
understanding you know the underlying
reasons and and the likely sort of
follow-through of these things and how
persistent they will be Ben looks lucky
yeah sort of a couple of points about
the nature of our forecast I mean first
I don't think they're intended to
communicate something say about future
policy historically they're intended
more
to explain the current decision
because of these long lags in policy we
have to make forecasts sometimes I wish
we didn't but we have to make full costs
and uh
we use them to explain the current
decision rather than to say here's what
we're going to do for the next two or
three years
the second thing I'll say from the
beginning this was always viewed as very
important and is still very important
they are fan trials
their probability distributions they're
not Point estimates they're not Point
forecasts
and that should be understood and then
the third thing is something we said
earlier is they're conditional
and people on the outside may have
different conditions and that's fine
there are loads of people who make
forecasts I don't think people think
okay well I'm going to rely only on the
bank of England who makes a particular
kind of forecast
indeed a whole range of numbers within
the fan
so I'm not sure it's we view it as a
kind of communication device
about what will happen in the future if
still less what will happen to interest
rates